point a is that negative five comma five
so this is negative five right over here
this is one two three four five that's
five right over there so point a is
right about there so that is point a
just like that at negative five comma
five and then it's a center of circle a
which I won't draw just yet cuz I don't
know the radius of circle a point B is
that let me sir let me underline these
in the appropriate color point B is it 3
comma 1 so 1 2 3 comma 1 so that's point
B right over there it's a center of
circle B Point P is at 0 0 so it's right
over there at the origin and it is on
circles a and B well that's a big piece
of information because that tells us if
this is on if this is on both circles
then that means that this is b's radius
away from the set from the point b from
the center and this tells us that it is
circle a's radius away from its center
which is at Point a so let's figure out
what those radii actually are and so we
can imagine let me draw let me draw a
radius or the radius for circle a we now
know since P sits on it that this could
be considered the radius for circle a
the radius for circle a and you could
use the distance formula but we'll see
that the distance formula is really just
falling out of the Pythagorean theorem
so the distance formula tells us the
radius right over here this is just the
distance between those two points so the
radius or the distance between those two
points squared is going to be equal to
our change in X values between a and P
so our change in X values we could write
it as negative 5 minus zero squared
negative 5 minus zero squared that's our
change in X that's our change in X
negative five minus zero squared plus
our change in Y 5 minus 0 5 minus 0
squared which gets us that are our
distance between these two points which
is the length of the radius school
is equal to negative five squared
negative five squared plus five squared
or we could say that the radius is equal
to the square root of this is 25 this is
25 5050 we can write as 25 times 2 so
this is equal to the square root of 25
times the square root of 2 which is 5
times the square root of 2 so this
distance right over here is 5 times the
square root of 2 now I said this is just
the same thing as the Pythagorean
theorem why well if we were to construct
a right triangle right over here if we
were to construct a right triangle right
over here then we can look at this
distance this distance would be the
absolute value of negative 5 minus 0 or
you could say 0 minus negative 5 this
distance right over here is 5 this
distance is 2 the distance between 0 & 5
in the Y Direction that's 5 Pythagorean
theorem tells us that 5 squared which is
25 plus 5 squared another 25 is going to
be equal to your hypotenuse squared and
that's exactly what we have here now you
might be saying wait wait wait this
thing had a negative 5 squared here
while here you had a positive 5 but the
reason why we could do this is when you
square it the negative disappears the
distance formula that you could write it
this way where you're taking the
absolute value and then it becomes very
clear that this really is just the
Pythagorean theorem this would be 5
squared plus 5 squared 5 squared plus 5
squared the reason why you don't have to
do this is because the sign doesn't
matter when you square it it always it
will become a positive value
but either way we figured out this
radius now let's figure out the radius
of circle be the radius of circle be the
radius of circle be same exact idea the
radius of circle be squared is equal to
our change in X so go from from if we
could be we could write it as 3 minus 0
or 0 minus 3 but we'll keep we'll just
write it's 3 minus 0 3 minus 0 squared
plus 1 minus 0 squared or the radius or
the distance between these two points is
equal to the square root let's see this
is 3 squared plus 1 squared just 9 plus
1 this is the square root
10 the radius of B is the square root of
10 now they asked us which of the
following points are on circle a circle
B or both circles so all we have to do
now is look at these points if they are
square root of if this point is the
square root of 10 away from point B then
it's on the circle
it's a radius away a circle is the locus
of all points that are that are a radius
away from the center if it's 5 square
roots of 2 from this point then it's on
circle a if it's neither then it's
neither or it could be both so let's try
these out one by one
so Point C is at 4 negative 2 so let me
color this in a new color
so Point C let me do an orange Point C
is that 1 2 3 4 negative 2 Point C is
right over there now it looks pretty
close just you know this is a hand-drawn
drawing so it's not perfect so Point C
is there it looks pretty close but let's
actually let's actually verify it
the distance between Point C and point D
so the distance squared is going to be
equal to the change in X's so we could
say 4 4 minus so we're trying this
between C and B it's 4 minus 3 squared 4
minus 3 squared plus negative 2 negative
2 minus 1 squared negative 2 minus 1
squared which is equal to this is 1
squared plus negative 3 squared and so
our distance squared is equal to is
equal to 10 or our distance is equal to
the square root of 10 so this is also
the distance right over here is the
square root of 10 so this is on the
circle if we wanted to draw a circle B
it would look something like this and
once again I'm hand drawing it so it's
not perfect but it would look something
I'm going to draw a part of it it looks
something like this this is exactly a
radius away so let me write this is on
Circle Circle B now let's look at this
point the point 5 comma 3 so I'll do
that in pink
so one two three four five comma three
so this looks close but let's verify
just in case so now our distance is
equal to let me just write it this way
our distance squared is going to be our
change in x squared so five minus three
squared
five minus three squared plus three
minus one squared change in Y three
minus one squared and so our distance is
going to be equal to actually I want to
skip too many steps see this is two
squared which is four plus two squared
which is another four so our distance is
going to be equal to the square root of
eight which is the same thing as the
square root of two times four which is
the same thing as 2 times the square
root of 2 square root of four is two and
then of course you just have the two
left and the radical so this is a
different distance away than square root
of ten so this one right over here is
definitely not on circle B and just
eyeballing it you can see that it's not
going to be on circle a this distance
you're just just eyeballing it is much
further much further than five square
roots of two and that's also true for
Point C Point C is much further than
five squared so too you can just look at
that you can just look at that visually
they're much further than a radius away
from a so this point right over here
this is neither this is on either circle
now finally we have the point negative
two comma eight so let me find I'm
running out of colors let me see I could
use I could use well I guess I'll use
yellow again negative two comma eight so
that's negative two comma one two three
four five six seven eight so it's right
it's right over here that is point e
just eyeballing it this distance so it's
clearly way too far just just looking at
it just eyeballing it's clearly more
than a radius away from B so this isn't
going to be on circle B and also looking
at it relative to point a it looks much
closer to point a you know it doesn't
even seem close then point P is so it
looks just inspecting that you could
rule this one out but this is going to
be neither
but we can verify this on our own if we
like we can just find the distance
between these two points our distance
squared is going to be our change in X's
so negative two minus negative five
negative 2 minus negative five squared
plus our change in Y so it's eight minus
five squared and so this is our distance
squared is going to be equal to negative
two minus negative 5 that's negative two
plus five so that's going to be three
squared plus three squared and you see
that right over here Pythagorean theorem
this distance right over here is 3 this
distance right over here this is your
change in X is three change in Y is
three three squared plus three squared
is going to be the distance squared the
hypotenuse squared so our distance
squared is going to be or I can say our
distance skip a few steps is equal to
the square root of we can write this as
9 times 2 or the distance is equal to
three times the square root of 2 the
radius of circle a is five times the
square root of two not three times the
square root of two so this is actually
going to be inside inside the circle so
if we want to draw a circle a it's going
to look something like it's going to
look something like this it's going to
look something like this and point e
point e is on the inside point D and
point C are on the outside of circle a
the only one that sits on any of the
circles is point is point
C